-Ana, it is always great
to see you.
You look fantastic.
You helped me out.
You were on my show
"That's My Jam."
-Yes, it was so fun.
-And thank you for doing that.
I think you're perfect
for that show.
You were, like, one of
the first people I thought of
when we were doing the show,
'cause you're so great at comedy
and you're so very musical.
-I try.
-Did you enjoy yourself?
-I loved it, 'cause I loved that
I got to be there "'SNL' Night."
So I was there with
Fred and Melissa
and, of course,
my beloved Uncle Dratch.
-Uncle Dratch.
-Rachel Dratch? You call her --
-Rachel Dratch, yes,
who is my work husband
because we wrote that
"Clusterfunke" movie together.
-That's the last time
you guys were together.
-Yeah, yeah. So we came to
get together, right.
-That was so funny.
-So, the whole thing about
"That's My Jam" is --
I have to tell you something.
And this is true of
this show, too.
You deliver
a quality swag product.
The Jimmy Fallon brand.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-We have some good merch.
The Jimmy Fallon brand.
-Yeah, so, you -- For doing --
For "That's My Jam,"
which was such a delight --
and I'm not lying about this --
there was a tote
that you gave us.
There was a
"That's My Jam" tote.
Fred and I have called each
other several times to say,
"This tote is amazing."
We take it to
the farmer's market.
-Yeah.
-We take it to the beach.
-It's a quality tote bag.
-Fill it --
You take it on a plane.
It's a quality tote.
It had a nice -- You could put
it over the shoulder.
You could take
it wherever you want.
-Carry it in your hand.
You could --
-Carry it out there like that
with weight in it
and work your --
-You know, but sundries.
-Put sundries in there
and whatnot.
-Any kind of thing.
So, I love that tote so much
that I was going to knock it off
when I gave my Season 2
wrap gift for "American Auto,"
because you give a crew gift,
and I thought,
"Well, Jimmy is classy,
and he gives classy gifts,
so I'll do it."
And I looked up the price.
It was so expensive.
I couldn't do it.
-So you didn't
give any presents at all?
-No, I gave it
a much lower-grade tote.
[ Laughter ]
I mean, it's nice.
It said "American Auto."
It looked good.
And you could farmer's market --
You could maybe do a
quick IKEA run.
-That was a good tote.
-Maybe a quick -- You could do a
quick IKEA run if you wanted,
but I'm not sure the seams
could handle a Home Depot run.
That's what I'm trying to say.
But yours --
Your the "That's My Jam" bag --
that's a Home Depot purchase.
-Yeah. But through
all the years
of everything you have done,
your movies and shows
and things -- and you have to
have swag from different things.
-So much swag.
And it always makes me laugh,
because there's --
It's cool, but it's also
deeply embarrassing
to be seen in public
advertising your own product.
You know what I mean?
-I do.
-To be marching -- My husband
left the house one day.
He's not conscious of
these things.
He left one day for work
and he was wearing --
I was in "Wicked,"
the Broadway show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, yes, thank you.
He left one day for work in
a "Wicked" sweatshirt,
"Wicked" backpack,
and "Wicked" umbrella.
Like, a completely --
And he's a big guy.
-You go,
"Charlie, pick one, bud."
-Pick one, and also,
like, "Wow, man.
You really like Broadway."
You know?
But do you remember --
I have such a fond memory,
because "SNL" -- Again,
I think the great tradition of
all Lorne Michaels' shows,
"SNL" gives
really beautiful swag.
We still have --
Because we come from the GE era.
So we would get like --
-TVs.
-TVs and stuff, yeah.
I mean, in the 90s.
-VCRs.
-I have such
a strong memory of you,
because it must have been --
It was a big anniversary.
It was like
the 25th or the 35th.
I don't know. It was a big year.
Anyway, I don't know --
somebody in charge of swag
decided that what
would be a cool thing
to have is
a small, black leather...
-Pillow?
-...pillow.
A throw pillow.
And it said "SNL."
-It was a small leather pillow.
-Do you remember?
-It wasn't -- It's not quite an
American Girl-doll-sized pillow,
but it's like a doll pillow --
-Did you keep it?
-I want to say yeah.
I think I still have it.
-Is it in your R.V.?
Where did you --
-I don't know.
Where would I put it?
I don't know where -- It doesn't
go with anything I do.
-I guess if you shot porn or
something in your house,
then it might be cool.
-I might not have it.
I might not have it.
-No, I don't think it's you.
You would --
That's not your brand.
Like, but what I'm saying is,
I feel like that is --
I'm not sure
who this is designed for
and that I'm not ungrateful,
because I know it cost
a lot of money.
-No, we both --
-On the secondary --
-Do we leave holding it?
Weren't we both, like --
-I remember coming into
the hallway,
and you were just creeping out
of your door like,
"Did anybody else
get this pillow?"
And you were very --
-We were neighbors.
We were neighbors.
-We had so much fun.
-We really, really did.
-Well, I want something from
"American Auto" now,
because Season 2 is back.
-We got key fobs.
We got cool key --
Well, it's Payne Motors, right?
-Payne Motors is
a great name, by the way.
Congrats, by the way.
You know you're 100% on
Rotten Tomatoes.
Like, it's a Fresh --
Certified Fresh rating.
-Certified Fresh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's a big deal.
-Thank you.
-Season 1, Certified Fresh.
-Certified Fresh.
I am really proud of it.
I think it's really funny.
It's a great NBC
half-hour workplace comedy.
-Who runs that show?
-Justin Spitzer.
He created "Superstore."
-Yeah.
-And he wrote on "The Office"
for 10 years.
I mean, he definitely
understands, like, "the DNA."
And it is a famous, non--
You know, fictitious automotive
manufacturing company.
And I come in as the new female
C.E.O., Katherine Hastings.
And I don't drive.
So -- And I come from
Big Pharma,
so some gray areas
there, morally.
-Yeah, it's very, very funny.
-And, yeah -- And it's
a great ensemble comedy.
I'm really excited about it.
-I also love that you get to do
some physical comedy, too.
-I guess I do get to do
some physical comedy.
I don't really
think of it that way.
But we're in crisis a lot
over there at Payne Motors.
So our stock price
is really in the toilet.
So we're really working on
getting our way back.
-Yeah.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Ana Gasteyer in
"American Auto."
Take a look at this.
-It's going to be okay.
-[ Laughs ] No, no, no.
It's not going to be okay. Okay?
We all know it's not
going to be okay.
I mean, I tell you guys
it's going to be okay,
and you know why?
-Uh...
-'Cause you don't lose?
-No! I tell you
it's going to be okay
so that you all
don't panic, okay?
I mean, outside,
I'm all like, "Hey, guys,
everything is
going to be just fine.
Brighter days tomorrow.
Cheer up, okay?"
Do you want to know what
I'm thinking inside?
Would you like to know
what I am thinking inside?
-Yeah, yeah.
-[Bleep] [bleep] [bleep]
We're all [bleep]
All of us are [bleep]
Alright!
-Come on! That is...
[ Cheers and applause ]
That's standing over a cliff.
-Oh, come on.
-That's what I'm talking about.
That's fantastic.
-I try. I try.
-Yes. Oh, my gosh.
We love you.
Ana Gasteyer, everybody.
"American Auto" is on NBC...
-What?! Look at this tote!
Look at this tote!
-"American Auto"
airs Tuesdays at 8:30 on NBC,
streams on the next day
on Peacock.
More "Tonight Show"
when we come back.
-That is quality.
-Look at this.